hey I was going rez - brah welcome to
within deep sorrows this game was
recently released and it looked pretty
[ __ ] scary so here we go yay 19:58
sank williams so this is the place
whoa oh did you see that oh my gosh
someone knows I'm coming
I bet Nia its Locke of course of course
we're gonna have to find another
entrance oh my god I got a paperclip
block
there ya go you like that you'd like
everyone I took all you Oh dorable what
how did I how did I get here that
doesn't make any sense
Oh God we're [ __ ] huh what does he say
math oh god no two plus two is five no
way what's the plan alright put the key
in the hole and switch to switch that
refrigerator is leaking oh [ __ ] me what
was that
Oh God can I a man enjoy an ugly
painting in peace hello oh goes dark
it's [ __ ] dark huh what are you doing
they what oh my god whoa oh it was a
nipple oh god save me
oh no not colors and squares oh wow that
would chair was scary so I will just
assume that whoever this guy is or girl
is on a lot of drugs a lot a lot of
drugs on batteries long life ones does
that mean my flashlight will work now do
I have a flashlight oh where did you
come from what the hell all right let's
check the cafeteria I see a little plate
here that is probably a metaphor for
life life doesn't get served on a plate
isn't that right cafeteria how is that
even possible that one was there I mean
the other one obviously was there what
are you even doing there somebody's glue
you there to be funny I get it this is a
metaphor for holes life is full of them
especially cheese you think I'm scared
of you little ambience not this guy not
one bit
not even a tiny little vagina fart oh
god oh god oh
Hardman good no no woman woman what are
you doing here I suck a bear Oh what am
I gonna do with a sec I don't even know
what a sack barrow is okay okay ugly
ugly gentlemen never do
whoa oh [ __ ] don't look oh [ __ ] that's
Kimmy what is this sack barrel this is
covering my face I think am i bein yam
bean I'm being yes the chair oh I'm the
worst Bing Bing good yes I place down
the chair
Hey whoa did you brush see that shadow
I'm sorry I'm sorry for a cut I'll just
stop with the big boys I'm sorry I'm
sorry
whoa whoa what happened invisible
furniture it's a paring a front of my
face can I jump I cannot climb before go
around this iton I must use my vein mask
to put this over here because [ __ ] logic
oh no my my brain man I'm no longer
brain well god damn II I was like the
best part of this game wasn't a
gentleman whoa cut cut cut scene cut you
hello God is his jump-scare [ __ ] me
Oh God behind me or upfront me or
someone is tickling my ass right now
no no jump-scare I suspect a hard one in
my ass sometimes I really need to listen
to myself oh god what's happening Cher
are you part of some sort of art
installation okay what what what what
what what's gonna happen better people
Jim a baby bears have a beauty bag I
miss you a lot how are you I'm great
I miss you a condom man this game
reminds me of condemned actually obey
whoa
three-dimensional blood that is awesome
and that is like my favorite
you can't put a shadow underneath the
blood man oh okay
Oh God the ambience man oh [ __ ] what
we're gonna have to fix that so man okay
I got it
Jimmy how do you a chair me how you
doing Jimmy Jimmy may I say you look
quite flat why thank you puked
it's my new boob job really I don't you
don't you don't look like you have to
what happen yes I mean your tits are
beautiful that's right [ __ ]
hi Jimmy doing some work on that door
[ __ ] yeah Jimmy hello
[ __ ] this okay all right
door number one found the key where does
it go
even Edgar got scared
sorry main Oh May okay
I just learned something very vital you
did not walk in on a girl taking a [ __ ]
scary things will happen I am now the
scarred for life
thank you I I knew you were part of an
art installation chain go to the light I
will follow you one day one day
no no no no no no one saw me no I'm Sami
no one saw me I'm pretty sure only share
and pee-pee and jemmye sorry and sacks
crop Squatch
scrag ja I don't know no one tell me I
swear to god we pay back my baby bag
about paper that's not even French are
you real prepare wait wait
of course really where's your mustache
[ __ ] this one is for the boys with the
Balmer system top down AC with the cola
system wedeck when i coming in the club
debbie blazing up sex
oh god how god i have been seen oh god
oh god oh god we must continue on you
piece of [ __ ] flashlight you were
supposed to be long living app oh god
[ __ ] that don't man what hi hey oh god
what happened what was that
Oh laughing fell down okay cool oh I
love it
Oh guys all right well loves us not so
bad well this is a lovely school isn't
it we have pancakes and they have
sexsquatch sack squash get back on my
face man I enjoyed been made whoa what
what what is happening I swear to God I
saw something I'm not crazy I'm pressing
a stop telling me what to do game sack
Squatch oh I'm turning the machinery off
so the flavor will step
what what are you doing Jenny fat habit
I became on a diet for you
are you sell fat am I supposed to pick
you up really oh the flashlight oh oh a
light bulb
well it's working [ __ ] amazing holy
[ __ ]
I could know that Tirpitz Shh how did
the foot get on there what that [ __ ]
okay now we can go up here with the the
don't don't toast my nipples okay do it
all day
exit how nice
why would an exit be on the second floor
I'm not that stupid okay thank you thank
you into the darkness we journey like
real men not to get a [ __ ] I'm scared of
[ __ ] literally it smells and it just
freaks me out man
hello don't mind me I'm just a little
schoolgirl
everyone knows schoolgirls never dies
because they're pure and innocent sir
you didn't have to eat it if you didn't
want to
no one forced you man no one forced you
to eat the chicken nugget this is let's
just get out of here Oh what the [ __ ]
hi
and the new girl in school my name is
Rafaela hi I came from Connecticut and I
love to paint flowers and I hope I make
many friends in class no I don't laugh
at me don't laugh at me don't let my
hair is beautiful my mom may dare my mom
made my hair what what I'm gonna click
anything all right well I got a key
I mean of course Janie has pants find
the key I didn't even know where it goes
to now you go first Brice I'm just gonna
I'm gonna stay here make sure the coast
is clear
yes you can't well it looks like I have
to do everything
god damn it breath you lazy bum okay I'm
sorry you're beautiful fantastic don't
kill me okay what is this ah where our
muscle this is clearly a lesson about
mapping we have bait Barker's diary a
diary that will help me progress open
diary if that doesn't work I don't even
understand this game anymore
this game just lost all logic whoa
John you cat any [ __ ] man can jump
that's slow mo job holy [ __ ]
Oh
ah we woke up and the place still looks
like [ __ ] oh no no not this game I don't
like this game you're welcome alright so
that was within deep sorrow it was
spooky it has some gems case and it
tickled my heart with an hour.get
octagram octagon yeah if you enjoyed
watching leave a like I'd really
appreciate it it's a skyrim road today
I'll leave a link to this if you want to
check it out yourself stay awesome bros
see you in the next one
love you
I wish